[Music]
[Applause]
know it you know it
[Music]
happy Monday November 13th and that is a
recording done by the one and only tiny
sand whoo
tiny sand who dropped us another
recording and through the email they
don't want to thank you tiny sand who
whatever you are you know I thought
about this the other day I'm thinking to
myself well dude what is a tiny sand who
you know have you ever been around one
do you know what tiny saying who what is
it you know what is it it's animal you
know it's a sapling you know it's a you
know it's a it's a you know it's
something that's you know like a small
wiener what is it it's something
competin it's something you can't pet
what is a tiny sand whoo and I have no
idea
I have no idea but if you don't know if
you if you if you want to think about
what a tiny sand do is you go ahead and
think about it as well because anybody
can think about anything that's one
thing I know for sure you know I'm
saying boy I'll be thinking about things
people could say you can't do this you
can't do that but when you look inside
of my head if you could see the picture
shows that's going on because I'd be
thinking about it all but there he is
whatever that beautiful animal is tiny
saying whoo playing a little bit of Guns
N'Roses Paradise City underwater and it
had me thinking where is my Paradise
City you know I'm always gonna live in
you know in turmoil I'm always gonna
live you know an uncertainty or am I
gonna choose the next time that I you
know step out of my truck or step off of
my bed in the morning you know am I
gonna choose that okay today wherever my
feet are this is my paradise sit a you
know because it can be your promised
land if you make it your promised land
you know and sometimes it just starts
with a promise to yourself that your
perception and
the way you look at things is gonna be a
little bit brighter because trust me I'd
drug around a dirty dirty sack of bad
attitudes for at least 15 years more
maybe even more if I could remember more
years in my life I would say definitely
more and so I know what it's like to
carry that negative attitude that
negative energy around and I don't
recommend it I don't recommend it to
anyone I honestly do not thank you guys
for joining me man I'm so happy to be
here it is Monday November 13th thank
you guys for joining me on this past
weekend man I had a wild one man I had a
wild one I have to let you know that I
will be in Huntsville Alabama this
Thursday the 16th through Sunday the
19th Friday night I'm just featuring for
a local gentleman they have a special
show going on but I will be on stage but
if you're gonna come out just to see me
I recommend Thursday Saturday Sunday as
well I want to let you know and thank
you
gray block pizza that's gray block pizza
in Santa Monica
ooh Los Angeles they say you don't got
pizza guess what you do gray block pizza
good as it gets
tastes like you've had it before and
it'll make your mouth wish that it was a
stomach because after you swallow it
your mouth gets greedy that it only had
it for such a short time and think your
stomach's gonna be holding on to it for
a while that's great block pizza but I'm
here I'm coming from Laughlin Nevada do
you even know that don't assume where
I'm at okay I'm coming to you from
Laughlin Nevada or Nevada drove up here
yesterday do it a show at a church and
it was at st. John I believe it was a
st. John Church dude I thought it was
gonna go swimmingly
and it went off the rails I mean I
thought it was gonna be like a side room
of a church right you think you're
getting a gig at a church and look I can
handle it people you know think my
material is super edgy sometimes but a
lot of it's not you know I got a lot of
great you know I can tell the stories
and you know and share stuff from my
childhood and I can keep people you know
intertwined like that and Inter tuned
didn't what's going on
but man I got in there and it was in the
actual church dude we're like the
Reverend and the preacher the pastor
where he preaches you know it was in his
it was in his doghouse right there at
the front and next thing you know I get
up I'm telling a few jokes and I used
the word erect erect in erect is when a
your penis starts looking around for
some you know for some other crotch you
know or even hell if it's been a long
time could be your own crotch you know
even if it's like your penis heard
something in a distance you know
sometime even if you're Peter you know
you know that's what it is though
and I said erect and some people walked
out and I mean look I don't blame him
you know I'm saying erect I'm in a
church but man it it didn't go
swimmingly so then I had to stop telling
jokes right so suddenly one of the
parishioners in the crowd just raises
their hand and asks a question so now we
started it into a conversation right and
then I get people laughing they're
asking questions I'm sharing things from
I'll I've just experienced from my own
life we get it going and and I really
feel a lot of gratitude because those
people saved the day instead of sitting
there and being miserable about what was
going on you know about well this guy's
appears you know you know dropping
erection words into the air they decided
to be like well let's get involved and
let's you know let's change the vibe and
I was able to be you know open enough to
change the vibe when we kept the app we
kept the energy going and then for about
30 minutes we did a Q&A that was full of
laughter and joy a lot of the people
were senior citizens and you know I grew
up with the senior citizen my father was
a senior citizen when I was when I was
born my father born in 1910 and so
suddenly I had this ground to really
relate to them on and we were all just
sharing stories and it was in it turned
out being a pretty good experience but
at first it was a really bad experience
I mean I am I was sweating sweating in
front of about a hundred people in the
small church that asked me to come and
perform and well you know sometimes you
get gigs like that that's the thing you
know I've had gigs where I flew and um
you know Guantanamo Bay and I got to do
there one time was you know amazing and
then sometimes you have gigs where you
are sweating in front of people at a
church and they're coming to your aid
you know man so that was that just
happened this evening here in Laughlin
Nevada good people and I and and one of
them started talking about rheumatism
during the show you know we're talking
to each other because at the end it was
cute like I could not tell any more
jokes I was so afraid to tell any jokes
that I was gonna really offend someone
so and one of the seniors mentioned
rheumatism and I don't know what
rheumatism is you know and I was like
well is it a like when you're in a room
and you know you're really scared you
know you're like scared of being in that
room and and they were laughing and then
I was like because if it is that's what
I have right now I have rheumatism
because man I was I it was one of the
toughest moments I've had in the show
that's that's for sure what else man oh
I went to Repticon this weekend and
Repticon that's reptiles and con men
which are really people it's not con man
it's people that sell reptiles you know
but they're definitely trying to for one
three four one you know throwing in a
salamander you know throw in a swirly
frog you know throw in a you know one of
these little Buster Douglas Douglas
geckos you know I'm like I said it's
real it had a scientific name he's like
it's all black you know it's a little
bit blue around the eyes it's a Buster
Douglas Gecko and I'm like well I guess
Buster Douglas might have had some
difference you know his unique skin
tints but that seemed like a wild name
but I got to watch them tarantulas have
sex and that that's alarming dude that's
alarming when you see tarantulas first
the first thing I notice about a
tarantula was they if you hold on to a
tarantula you can barely feel it in your
hand you can barely feel a tarantula and
it can be sneaking around on your skin
and you don't even know it can be just
kind of bouncing around your skin and
you don't even know like it's looking
for Easter candy I mean and do it they
there's something about them where you
I mean it felt like this [ __ ]
knew me and knew that I had cheated on
some of my taxes before that's exactly
what this thing the second they kept
putting it on me they say we go straight
up try to go straight him on like it was
going from a heart you know like it was
trying to be like it was gonna go inside
of me or something and see what was
going on inside of me very scary very
very scary for me
you know them tarantulas are ranches you
know or Julis some people call them
jewels but I think that that might even
be racially offensive to Latinos I don't
know if it is but it felt like it was
when I was saying you know let me get
them shoeless you know and look at these
Chile's [ __ ] because we got to watch
them have sex I was down there working
for the Chive I was doing some for the
Chive and the Chive is a vegetable
you know it's ditch onions but it's also
a website where you can look at breasts
and pictures of cats and animals and fun
stuff like that and I was down there
doing some work for them and we went to
Repticon and dude the people that work
at these conventions I don't have
anybody ever been involved in a
convention but the people that work at
conventions dude it's why old you know
there but a lot of wrong do they're
drinking their own uppers you know you
know they're in the back hit and you
know bombing up their insides with that
dust you know getting funny on that puff
puff you know they're doing it all you
know a lot of marette are back there
just respec and their innards with that
freaking kool-aid powder you know what
I'm saying and that's that [ __ ] that i
make it that'll make a jug that'll make
a jug of sugar water you know come
crashing through your wall you know
kool-aid man remember that commercial
kool-aid man can well a lot of these
people that work at these at these shows
and these you know these um these things
are like that they do a lot of rolling
uppers so you be in the bathroom and
these people out there you know they're
popping little quail uppers and you know
quaaludes and you know buzz saws and
freakin whisper bears or whatever they
need to get it in their system to stay
awake you know that cocaine you know
they don't want juice powder or whatever
they're doing you know what I'm saying
that freaky
they're back there snorting uh you know
snortin [ __ ] dried-up starburst crust
and all kinds of [ __ ] like that just to
make themselves feel get that high but
then they're out there slinging snakes
and reptiles
dude one guy had this little bin this
little Rubbermaid ban had about 200 baby
tarantulas in it think about that dude
they were so little
man I was I look I was scared like in
the beginning we got there and they had
a you know had to hold a snake and look
I've been around snakes you know when I
was growing up one of my best friends
used to uh he's best friend for a little
while and he was also real angry boy in
our town and he used to always go catch
snake because he couldn't say s so he
used to go catch snake and he'd make you
go cat snake with him and he would get
pissed if you didn't go kept faith so
dude he'd be like come on man we're
gonna get some flake and I did not want
to go with this dude but I did not want
to get beaten by him either
so the fear that I felt as a child
having to hunt snakes when I didn't want
to be hunting snakes cuz I didn't even
like snakes okay but also the fear was
if I didn't hunt for snakes that I was
gonna get my ass beat and that was scary
that was scary for me that was scary for
me so I think some of this brought back
feelings of that you know of um of
hunting faith and all of that and just a
lot it was a lot going on but it was a
wild weekend for me I went in saw
Morrissey I saw Billy Idol I haven't
been to a concert in Los Angeles in a
long time
like at the Hollywood Bowl they have a
huge place you can see the a concert and
I know this show is all over the place
right now look it's just some it's it's
some time it's gonna be like that you
know that's the week that's the weekend
it's midnight right now I'm in Laughlin
you know and uh and that was the weekend
that I had but it was it was a lot of
joy to man and you guys hit with a lot
of calls I didn't post up the are
this week because there wasn't a lot of
interest in it and so I don't think
we're gonna have Ariane anymore and
that's not a knock - Ari I love Ari
there may be a reason in the future but
at the time I think we're just gonna
keep things kind of like it is and I
hope to get into some call ins
we've got a new producer that's gonna be
helping me out on Wednesday we're gonna
put out a Thursday episode this week as
well so I'm really I'm really excited
about that
and that's just some of the new stuff
that's going on that I wanted to fill
you guys in on also last week we were
talking about what's real right and I
didn't get to uh there was a voicemail
that I put up on the patreon because
I'll do you know after content on the
patreon and you can be a part of patreon
if you want patreon.com slash Theo von
th EO vo in every little bit helps man
we're so grateful to the donors man the
gun squad people are contributing $10 a
month to help out it does mean a lot
we're gonna be putting a lot of good
stuff on there so thank you but last we
were talking about what's what's real
you know and a call or drop this callin
to me and always want to play it for you
guys so you guys have an idea of it just
kind of put me on a good note I should
have played it at the end last week but
I didn't here we go hey what's up Theo
it's Michael from California hey man I
just asked my girlfriend's father for
his permission to ask her to marry me
and he gave me his blessing felt really
good man it was one of times in a in
your life where it's just you know
asking a asking a father to marry his
daughter that's cool wow I'm still
thinking about it
that's it's like it an honor you know
it's an honor so ma'am I'm pumped he's
gotta go find a ring man there you go
so yeah I just wanted to play a little
bit of that call for you know we were
talking about things that are real we
talked about friends and family and how
that's something that's real but uh just
hearing that Michael right there you
know he did he went the old-fashioned
route hit up the daddy cat you know cuz
some of them you got a scratch daddy's
back if you want to play with his
daughter's breasts
you know and we all know that and
nothing any different from Michael
they're making that move congratulations
Michael you know that you you got the
dad's permission now you're halfway
there you know it's like you made the
first you know you hit the warp zone now
you just got to get up in the castle and
beat big Bowser you know you got to get
that lady to be on be on time with you
and you're gonna get that ring for and
that's beautiful man as beautiful
congratulations
it's been a good week it's been a good
week for me everything's still cruising
along what else did I do this weekend I
went let me see I went to Repticon I
went to the Morrissey did some shows had
a nice conversation with Kevin Nealon
Kevin Nealon at the Comedy Store you
remember him from SNL sweetest man I
mean just a nice guy to be around a
gentle soul that was good
and what else man I've been struggling
with the you know the mass tea
personally dude I thought things was
gonna be swell and usually my
masturbation flares up in the winter you
know my masturbation flares up in the
winter and I don't know why I don't know
if it's just I don't know if there's
more full moons in the winter or if
there's more
you know stray animals a lot of animals
that run away from home run away from
home in the winter at home and and I
know that's you know everybody pretty
much knows that but I think there's
something innate and a man you know when
these animals are out and about and
you're still you know and that makes us
growl that makes us want to just puff
out our chests and just touch ourselves
you know and I guess that's something
that was going on from me man I've just
been struggling with it and and you know
I know for some people it's not a
struggle but for me it is man when I get
home and I got zero plans to masturbate
you know to touch myself or to pleasure
myself and then you know three minutes
and 40 seconds later I find myself just
waddling towards the restroom with my
pants at my ankles you know and I got
the Lord's you know I got the I got the
Lord's uh you know cinnamon drippings
on the um you know on the outside of my
hands you know from doing dirty works to
myself it just makes me you know just
not something that I want to be doing
regularly I mean I'm trying to do to be
honest I'm trying to not do it for a
while that's the thing you know I'd be
okay with with masturbating or doing
touchy if I had and if I could take a
break from doing it but it's hard to
quit dude it's hard to quit touching
yourself you know I don't know I mean
what did I feel like sometime I feel
like my dick has cigarettes in it you
know cuz I don't know I mean there's
nothing that's harder I don't know
anything harder to quit you know they
just take a break from and I don't want
have to get a sponsor or somebody that
you know watches me at night that's
crazy but I'm thinking about it I'll be
lying to you if I didn't say I was
thinking about paying someone and watch
me at night for two hours Pam fifty
bucks an hour just for you know twenty
days or something too and I know you're
like well that's a thousand bucks yeah
it is but it also would be 20 days of
insurance where daddy you know ain't
being all naughty with himself you know
and ain't just you know and ain't just
making that fire water fly out of
himself you know for no real reason I
mean it's just I don't know
i'ma quit talking about it because I
don't want to be I don't want to think
down about myself and have too much
shame but that's why I'm mad man that's
what's been going on I got a lot of
response from the fighter in the kid
podcast I did it if you didn't get a
chance to hear hear it go check it out
that's with myself and Bryan Callen and
and Brendan Schaub I had a good time on
there and then I had a caller that it
gave a response to that to my appearance
on there and a discussion that happened
on there and I want to check that in
right now here we go
here what's going on man Pat from Mobile
Alabama that's my boy Pat from Mobile
and Pat only has one leg you know he
only has one leg dude think about
something that only has one leg you know
think about something that's Pat onward
you know still still [ __ ] hating the
hair bro but you know just you just got
to be
look in the mirror and say I'm gonna be
better but I wanted to say you know you
patent okay
people with one legs shouldn't throw
stones do you ever heard that you know
yeah I got bad hair dude you know I know
it it's humbling you know and if anybody
should know about humbling it's you my
brother and I respect what you do you
know I know you got you know you know
you ain't all limbed up like a lot of
people and a lot of people are taking
the easy way out I know it I know
sometimes when I'm standing up on both
of my [ __ ] legs
that I'm kind of a [ __ ] you know I
think about that sometime sometimes what
I'm standing on my legs I'm thinking
will damn Pat's out there on one leg
doing the same thing I'm doing you know
or not taking the easy way out and I
recognize that man you know we all have
our things you know and I got the hair
it's humbling
so I'll respect your humble game by
showing up you know with three limbs so
just respect my man I know it's nasty
dude I know I look like somebody that
sells [ __ ] indoor waterfalls in
Tennessee you know I know I look like
somebody that models land you know I
look like a supermodel at a [ __ ] swap
meet
I know I look bad dude you know I know I
look like to do that always farted you
know that's what this haircut does
brother this hey when you show up with
this haircut you are the viewer the dude
that farted doesn't matter but all more
Patrick I do appreciate your call man
and I love you I appreciate you calling
down there from Mobile Alabama I got a
beautiful half-sister and her family
live over there near Spanish fort onward
he said you never been around a black
man who's been nervous on the fighter
and the kid that's true well we had a
discussion on the fighter and the kid
the other day and actually had the same
discuss with my buddy James the other
day where I do black people get nervous
you know and that's I mean I understand
we are have nerves in our body but when
I think back in my life I can't ever
think of a black friend of mine telling
me he's nervous you know
unlike Jesus Christmas like that must be
awesome imagine not getting nervous like
it makes me think maybe I could be one
of the reasons why a lot of black guys
are better at basketball because every
time I got the ball I'm nervous as [ __ ]
imagine having no nerves and just being
able to rely on your abilities you know
in any case approaching women my black
buddies always better at approaching
women or I would say 90% of the time a
better at approaching women and I just
can I can't think of do black guys get
nervous you know and that's a call and
we can put that in a column for this
coming for this coming week and this
isn't or I'm not saying if you're taking
this as a race I'm not making fun this
isn't it'd be just like asking you know
trying to think up an idea or about any
ethnicity or any type of gender you know
whatever you know do black people get
nervous and I'm gonna talk to some black
friends of mine as well and have them
come comment on this because I want to
know I want to get to the bottom of this
but that's what the conversation was on
the fighter and the kid and that's what
our Pat is calling about here Pat let's
hear a little bit more and I got a
segment of two things that black
gentlemen get a get nervous about man
one our court sentences you look at a
black man's face during a court thing
[ __ ] they're sweating goddamn
bullet that's a good point dude that
might that might be true wow that's true
huh that's pretty true dude unless it's
like you know somebody who's like thug
in our front and which no matter what
color or ethnicity you are then those
dudes are always kind of like just being
hard but otherwise I guess maybe that
isn't that's an example of when black
guys get nervous okay onward okay
I'm telling their don't don't go to
Judge Judy go try to like a [ __ ]
c-span tight tight television like you
know I mean like the real boring [ __ ]
we've got an old-ass Judge so that's one
thing that gets [ __ ] nervous about
court stances number two [ __ ]
paternity test
man I had so many people I know
so when [ __ ] over hoping that DNA man
I know dudes who tried to [ __ ] put
bleach in that Google slob joining a guy
swab for the DNA she's my [ __ ] I put
bleach on that [ __ ] just so that that
DNA test comes out all types of [ __ ] Wow
so Pat knows some guys out there nah in
South Alabama who were trying to bleach
their way out of off of children's birth
certificates you know by by by dissing
franchising the test that women take
that vaginal you know swab factor that
lets us know you know if the baby if
there's even a baby I guess you know
damn that's gangsta but that's two good
examples that's two good examples Pat I
appreciate that
and if you guys have an example out
there if you think that's a good
question you know there's and there's
just some there's some innate
differences between people you know in
ethnicities and in genders of course but
I remember the first time I noticed a
real like intrinsic or on earth
intrinsics the word but a you know a
difference one time between me and a
black gentleman they had this boy in our
town named booboo Tyson and his brother
had set his leg on fire and they used to
call him ashy because his leg was asked
up and booboo had the nicest smile in
town man we played basketball together
for a few years we went to school
together for a few years
kind of like the town mascot I don't
think it was a person in town that
didn't love Boo Boo Tyson and Boo Boo
Tyson you know we had that leg was a
little bit crisped up so one of his legs
was a little bit leaner than his other
leg because it had been crisped it had
been crisped in a fire and and so boo
boo was constantly carrying you know
different type of lotion you know or
things you would put on horses stuff
like that heavy lotion intense lotion
you know stuff you had pack that they
packed ball bearings in on a car tire
like really real ass lubricants you know
I mean this dude would crack open a
ziploc bag full of you know [ __ ] that
they used on the damn NASA space jet you
know
you know things that could really a
mucus slick your hair back for you know
for probably about half a decade with
some of this pomade some of this heavy
heavy heavy grip and heavy softener this
boy carried and he would polish that up
into his leg you know and this reminds
me actually of you know my step
grandfather d'Artagnan and I talked
about it last week when he would let us
you know put lotion into his legs but
anyhow boo boo Tyson had that magic leg
by us and he used to uh he stashed that
thing up he used to put special you know
special SAVs and softeners on his leg to
you know keep that fire you know the
afflictions of that fire out of his leg
and away from everybody
I can't even what I was talking about
there what are we talking about why no
paddy called in and said that he had you
know that uh that people had different
issues what else happened man my brains
a little slow tonight guys it's midnight
usually I try to get in a little record
a little earlier but I had to drive her
to Laughlin today what were we talking
about
boo-boo Tyson oh well here's the time
that I noticed when booboo Tyson booboo
and booboo Tyson introduced me to one of
the most unique moments that I ever had
with a young black man at the first one
of the first most unique moments I ever
had with the young black man was we were
riding in the back of the truck
you know our basketball coach coach
Steve who you know he did you know he he
was a unique man and he was driving I
said to I out somewhere to do some work
down you know we're both in the back of
the truck and he drove it's about 60
miles an hour probably got 15 minutes
and he comes to a stop sign out in the
country and we stop and booboo and I
just couldn't even able to talk because
then Wynn had been going by so fast
we're just sitting in the back of an
open truck and booboo looks over at me
and he said man what's it like to have
your hair blow in the wind and that for
me was one of the first times that I was
ever like wow you know booboo he's never
gonna probably know what that's like you
know like not the same way I will and so
I just say you know I said well what's
it like
to not have your hair blow in the wind
you know that was my you know my answer
really and also does a question to kind
of you know to keep the conversation
just to make it I don't know just a
retort that I had that was my retorts
but it was interesting because I'd never
thought about that before and that was
one of the first times and I was like oh
wow you know there's just some people
some people will have different
experiences as simple as something to
have your hair blow in the wind that
boo-boo Tyson would never know about it
and at the time I couldn't think of any
of my black friends that would you know
or any black kids even in my town that
had long hair because at this time the
only person that I knew that had a jheri
curl type haircut was uh Raleigh Coleman
who was the vice principal at my school
with my junior high school and who also
used to sleep in the trunk of his car
around lunchtime and um and that was
wild why he did that and that could have
been issues from birth or maybe he got
you know he didn't want to be you know
he missed the womb or something I don't
know but uh but anyhow so that was that
was an interesting experience I had
early on but do black guys get nervous
do black guys get nervous if they don't
teach me how because most of my life is
anxiety but when I really think about it
I personally cannot think of a time that
a black friend of mine ever ever said to
me man I'm nervous can you if you can
tell me man hit the hotline nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
and we don't we need anything you know
nothing racial or jarring like that I'm
not looking for anything like that but I
am looking for just some unique
experiences or if you had a unique
experience that showed you a difference
between you and another ethnicity what
something that was like unique you know
that really gave you a perspective you
know that adjusting your perspective or
gave you a perspective a little bit I'd
love to know more all right let's move
into another call that came in here we
go hey deal this is false for speaking
from Brazil false stuff from bazzill man
and you know it's amazing man well I
forgot I've had a
a young lady called from Saudi Arabia
I've had people from Ireland call from
Britain and the British should we beat
the British and and here we are foster
from Brazil onward I just want to say
that I'm a big fan I first saw you on
Joe Rogan podcast and ever since I
watched every this weekend this past
weekend show thanks fast I appreciate
that man did I saw Joe the other night
in the hallway at UH at The Comedy Store
and I got a little bit nervous around
him sometime I just get nervous around
people whether either you know if I know
him or not and I can't so many like a
lot of fans were going up to him and
people loved him you know it's like it's
almost like for some people getting to
meet you know wow it's almost for some
people seem like they're getting to see
uh it's obviously like a celebrity to
some people but there's something else
more than that it's like they get to see
a little bit of a guru or a family
member that they haven't met or so I
don't know there's something unique
about it um the way that his that his
fans like him and I got kind of touched
by just watching that you know it's nice
to see people not enamored I mean
there's that aspect but there was
something else it's like it's like they
get to meet a little bit of a teacher
that they you know you know it's like as
if somebody dug up Aristotle and was
bringing his you know and they you know
attached some muscles and tendons and
blood and everything to his bones and
got him clicking again and then people
showed up him like you know we're
meeting him there was some excitement in
the air so uh but yeah so no I you know
anyway I don't know what I'm talking
about let's hear a little bit more
Fausta from Brazil and I think it's
awesome you seem to be a pretty cool guy
and I'm just calling to to say that uh
the beautiful day here in Brazil today
it's Sunday noon and I'm watching your
your podcast and just thought about
calling I'm 38 38 years old single
photographer here in San Paolo
big city and I'm just about to do some
mushrooms today it's a beautiful day
I do that every once you know every once
in a while
cool faster we'll look man I appreciate
it you know I knew I was want to play
that call because it was from abroad
just to let you guys know that we got
other people who were tuning in to all
of us and that that's pretty cool
thank you for us to get them shrooms in
you bro get your vision cracked out you
know oh man I missed that that's one
thing I miss bruh it's sprinkling those
indecencies rough you know just
management when you took on shrooms that
you know life was like a box of crayons
but when you had them shrooms and you
dome suddenly boy you was running on
that big kit that big 64 you know and
that's one thing I miss and love about
the mushrooms bro just treating yourself
with that fungus you know getting that
funky unggi up in you junkie junkie bruh
up in your brain jungle you know up in
your thought penitentiary
dude I man there was nothing better than
watching your eyes drip out of your
skull in a bathroom mirror at a
stranger's apartment and then coming out
of the bathroom and realizing it wasn't
a stranger's apartment it was your
apartment man that's one thing I miss
about mushrooms dude
going out in the field and picking them
you know someone could eat something one
time in a field it wasn't even a
mushroom it was something that had a pig
had coughed up and he got [ __ ] sick
and I'd go to the hospital for about
three weeks but do you know what [ __ ]
him man you know if you're out eating
mushrooms and you're eating other [ __ ]
off the ground dude you're an idiot you
know sometimes people are just an idiot
you know what else is going on man
there's a lot of stuff happening with
with well let's take one more listener
and then i'ma get in that people were
talking about some of these um just men
and female issues that's going on and
some of the conversations are going on
here and they're in the aftermath of the
louis c.k issue let me take one more
call here that came in here we go what's
going on well I'm from Pittsburgh man I
got pink I want a one time up there in
the Monongahela and and I got a [ __ ]
up there behind the giant eagle behind a
chain grocer and all a giant eagle is
it's just a it's just a Kroger in
disguise that's all that is but I got a
beautiful [ __ ] up there one time and
I got pinkeye and
onward [ __ ] take this job then I
often quit in the beginning of the week
my old job so I started with no money so
I mean it's been a week at this new
place I'm paying for gas which changed
there's I don't know if you know
anything about paying for gas with
change but it's an embarrassing act that
I've been forced to have to do almost
every day but I'm listening to you talk
about level ever seen on this [ __ ]
old dude play and sick water and I just
yeah
immediately pulled me out of my farm
Thank You man I appreciate it yeah
there's no better way to get to know a
grandparent than by putting or even a
step grandparent than by putting lotion
on their body in a non perverse way and
if you think I'm crazy to go do that you
know you may Matt you may have an
association with your grandparent now go
put lotion on their arms or legs you
know show them some tender love and some
tender care that's nonsense you and I
let's see how much better you know them
but I appreciate a man I appreciate it
I'm glad that uh that we can make you
laugh by and you know and not be
thinking about paying for for gas with
change you know I've been there I'm not
there today
thank God I might be there again but I'm
not there today but I have been there
and I commend you for you know getting
up getting your gas and getting where
you need to go
getting to work it sounds like that's
what you're doing so I appreciate that
call let's hear another call here here
we go and then we're going to get into
some of this other conversation yet that
the louis c.k issue is hot right now in
Los Angeles you know it's hot and you
know Louie's been stripped apparently of
a lot of his you know a lot of his
opportunity he came out with a statement
you know Louie was a louis c.k a famous
comedian was accused of you know i think
there's five instances and the article
that i've read so far there may be new
stuff i don't know there are five
instances of sexual indecency and that's
just a you know i don't know the exact
term that's the term i'm using but you
know there's five instances where he
asked people if he could jerk off in
front of him one of them said no and he
didn't and then
other people were like yeah or didn't
say anything or laughed and he kept
going and that's a wild thing man you
know to be jerking off in front of
somebody is brave you know
it's brave but also to be sitting
watching somebody jerk off is I mean you
know jerk off of somebody in front of to
jerk off in front of somebody's is it's
you know it's messed up it's ballsy it's
[ __ ] up if they don't want it if
you're looking at them and you can tell
they do not want that and you're
continuing to do that that's messed up
you know this is this messed up also to
sit there and watch somebody jerk off
when you don't want to be is kind of
messed up you know like leave the
[ __ ] room
you know like leave the room
somebody's jerking off dude I'm out you
know what I'm saying like knock knock
who's there not me you know I'm leaving
and I get you know I know they're just
some traumatizing instances and stuff
and but if somebody's not blocking the
door
adios bro and that's Spanish for I'm not
watching you jerk off you know I'm out
of here
but that's big out here in Los Santos
right now and a lot of men are afraid to
you know to speak anything right now a
lot of men are you know just scared it
definitely feels like a witch hunt in
Los Angeles it feels I mean any
instances of there's instances of like
you know of just a man looked at me this
way or a man you know a few years ago a
man said something kind of you know you
know rude or I mean it's just it's
baffling it's baffling and it's scary
and I think a lot of the country
probably is like you know you know this
is [ __ ] up whatever a lot of people
probably read the Louie Louie story in
the Louie article and we're like you
know yeah it's [ __ ] up but it just
seems like a
no kind of a [ __ ] up dude kind of a
pervy dude I'm not surprised I mean you
know dudes can be pervy you know and I'm
not making excuses I'm just I'm just uh
I guess I'm just you know I'm just like
some of it feels well here's what I
think is gonna happen I think in three
years Louie is gonna have one of the
biggest comedy tours ever I was at The
Comedy Store last night and Neal Brennan
is on stage and he asked the crowd you
know if Lou is performing in the next
room right now would you guys pay to go
see him and 95 percent of the crowd
clapped like cheered I mean I think one
unique thing about Louie being involved
in this scenario is that he's such a
he's so good at figuring out his own
thoughts and making them into relatable
conversation or even conversate maybe
the conversation is always relatable but
the humor and the conversation that he
uses is revealing and I think that it's
gonna be I think that at least by him
being involved in this you'll be able to
get I mean he's gonna come back with one
of the best hours of comedy ever and of
course the industry has to distance
themselves from him the you know
Hollywood industry and stuff like that
because you know they're all tied to
advertisers and and that sort of deal
but you know it's just gotten I think
it's gotten to the point some stuff
where some of this just just like when
does he you know how I don't know you
know I guess I don't know what's all my
thoughts are man but it just seems it's
just I mean it's definitely scary it's
scary in LA right now because there's I
mean accusations of just fly up on
Facebook every other day and you have no
kiddin do anything as a man and you get
accused that can be your ass that can be
your ass it doesn't even matter you know
there's a there's a governor in Alabama
or something that's running and there's
accusations against him of pedophilia
and obviously
not good not cool but but with this this
thing an age who knows if somebody
didn't just make someone say something
or have you know find some person to say
something to ruin a presidential
election it's like you just don't know I
mean we can't we can't just go on
accusations and I'm not specifying on
the you know the guy from Alabama
whatever Roy Moore but we just can't go
on accusations if we do it's just like
we're turning in that it's just gonna
turn into a witch hunt and I guess it's
scary for me because I'm a man you know
and we seem to be what's most popularly
being hunted right now and I don't think
that's everywhere but I do think that
it's um it's certainly like in a lot of
liberal circles you know and it's scary
and it's certainly by like a lot it's
just it's scary bruh is scary let me
take this call right here here we go yo
what's going on pimpin I'm from the
Greater Toronto Area out there in
Ontario Canada I just wanted to get your
thoughts on a little situation
so basically hmm hi just a girl from my
past reached out to me I I used to talk
to her in high school so she always has
always had a boyfriend so I never had a
shot okay so a girl from high school she
always had a boyfriend you never had a
shot on word and she recently just
reconnected with me she she reached out
she messaged me on some social media
outlet and we've been talking and
hanging out and things are getting kind
of close and she tells me she's tall she
has a boyfriend she's been seeing him
for five years but that there are
relationships on the rocks so I don't
know what to do here I don't know how to
handle this situation because I really
care about this okay so I mean just even
listen your own call right there man
you're saying that there's this girl's
he's always had a boyfriend so she
wasn't available and then you know and I
appreciate your call man and then you go
on to say and now she still has a
boyfriend and it seems like she's still
not available here's what I would do
I would put your hat in the ring I would
say look this is what I would like and
if she can do that then do that and move
on you know and move forward with her
you know you know I'd say look I'd like
to date you you know but I think getting
involved in this but you know if she's
got both boyfriend she got it just it's
not gonna be good it's not gonna end
well for anybody you know and that could
ruin your chance of being with her but
you're saying she had a boyfriend she
wasn't available and now she still has a
boyfriend so she's still really not
available you know and if you start off
on in that environment you know you
could and then one day she leaves you
for some other dude you couldn't be that
shocked you know if that's how it
started this way but I put your put your
thoughts in so hey look this is how I
feel you know this is what I want if
you're really into her now if you're
just trying to get a little bit of a
zum-zum then you know you know take her
some coffee and keep feeling that out
see where you guys are but if you really
want to ride the open road and get that
long-term vroom going with her then
maybe you are you just let her know how
you feel and take a step back let her
figure it out you know but look how you
know it depends on how much to your time
you want to waste that's what I think
for me that's what it would but I
appreciate your call man let's take
another call right here and this was a
little bit more about what's going on
with kind of men and some of their
thoughts and stuff these days onward
paddy field
your buddy Dylan green from up in
Northwest Bellingham Washington Oh dirty
Dylan green from Billingham onward Dylan
a couple times love your podcast you've
got to say you've been promoting this
thing that you're doing that has to do
with things concerning men and
masculinity and how your listeners may
feel as men and how we're treated and
communicated with in America and you
know well yeah I mean we're in a tough
time and we're certainly in a tough time
dude especially I mean like in Los
Angeles it is hell it's hell man I mean
I'm afraid to even jerk off with my cat
in the room you know and I don't even
have a cat
you know I do not even have a cat
but if I did I'd be afraid you know it's
just a scary time out here and I think
in a lot of America it's not like that
a lot of America people are still like
actually living and things are making
sense you know I mean you know people
are hunting louis c.k from 2005 he
wasn't even a celebrity then I mean he
was you know he was a good comedian but
he wasn't he wasn't the louis c.k that
we have today you know so I mean people
are witch-hunting for sure you know some
busted comedians you know but I'm not
saying what made him right but it's like
people are looking through things to
witch-hunt you know and maybe the guy's
a twist to dude maybe sick make I mean I
think if you were asked people to jerk
off and you're you know hey that's
[ __ ] just bizarre I don't know man I
mean when I was young my uncle would
show everybody his dick sometimes dude
we thought he was our uncle we didn't
think he was a [ __ ] we thought it was a
little bit pervy but we didn't think he
was a sick human we thought he was our
uncle you know but these people act like
they've never seen a [ __ ] dick in the
universe you know like you know like
Louie broke out of sack of kryptonite
you know I mean leave the [ __ ] room
as well you know I mean I just don't
like to the point where sometimes people
are you know so if it's just like you're
so effective because what like you you
have you ever been around in the world
where there's Dick's around leave you
know it's just some of us just bizarre
to me but let's hear more would you have
to say ma'am what and I'm in a little
bit of a rough mood it's midnight
tonight guys and I know I should have
gotten this done earlier but I had to be
on the road
and I'm but I am happy to be here with
you guys I'm just a little bit tired
let's hear more a lot of you know pretty
heavy liberal politics which you know a
lot of that I can get down with but man
I've been around a lot of these women
and I used to work in an office of nine
women I was only male and just hearing
this this these things from them of
saying that the world to tapes women
that the world is always out to get down
women and and when they say the world
that's kind of like their way of saying
well like manner does that get us and
and in the world is setting these
precedents for refute II and how we're
supposed to look and meanwhile I'm
sitting back and thinking to myself in
my buddies we love women yeah look I
appreciate and the world is set yeah and
they're like the world is setting this
precedent for how women first look men
aren't setting that precedent the
whoever owns the media is who's setting
those press the precedent these
magazines you know they're not hiring
look I'll tell you this dude attractive
people are still getting most of the
work in Los Angeles you know like the
law you know they'll be like oh well you
know Hollywood and the you know magazine
industry stuff like that you know like
um media they can be like well you know
everybody's you look however they want
and be everyone's beautiful in this and
that but then they're only taken mostly
the prettiest you know they ain't
picking up the ugliest people and giving
them work 98 percent of the time it's
not what they're doing you know so I
mean I agree it's bizarre it's like you
know the people that are making that
message are the same people that are
then coming back and saying who's making
this message you know it's the same
people most normal people who aren't
involved in that [ __ ] circle don't
give a [ __ ] you know if you have a wife
or a sister you want them to feel good
about the way that they look no matter
how they look you know most of us in the
world are eight or seven you know that's
how we look you know and we're okay and
we [ __ ] deal with it you know it's
easy for some beautiful person to be
like people should everyone's beautiful
no everyone's not most of us are eights
and sevens you're [ __ ] beautiful
you know once you come down here to
eight or seven Ville you know and then
see see whats cracka jackin onward each
and every one of us we respect them we
enjoy their company we're all seeking
from myself my buddies who are single
guys we're seeking quality authentic
relationships with women and none of us
are Talent
these chicks what to wear or what to
dress or how to dress you know it's uh
it's an interesting concept and I
sometimes wonder if some of these
standards are are really actually not
created by men at all but created by the
expectations that women put on
themselves and the way that they
communicate with each other you know
it's interesting man it's a really good
point and it's really well said too
I mean I wish sometimes that I was able
to as clearly articulate some of my
thoughts and feelings as you just did
there yeah a lot of times it's you know
it's um it's not men that are making
these demands or demanding anything I
mean if anything we just want to be able
to [ __ ] be alive these days you know
there's certainly this witch hunt by a
you know in the mainstream media where
men are that are bad you know and
especially white men you know even
though most of us didn't do [ __ ] you
know it's a tough time man it's a tough
time to be a man and it's a tough time
to speak up about being a man you know
and in world where you're supposed to be
able to say oh you know be free speak
your mind say your truth [ __ ] you
know [ __ ] some dude tweeted earlier
today I cannot even believe this right
my buddy sent me this on a text chain
right this was a tweet by a guy okay I'm
not even sure who tweeted it but this
was the tweet things I love to do to
women listen to them believe them
support them hire them be their friend
if they want share their perspective
tweet nice things about them amplify
their voices thank them love them in
parentheses how they want to be loved
yeah bro you know yeah that's true those
are all things that we want to do for
women but that just sounds like such
[ __ ] pandering like that's what
you're doing every day well you know
what the [ __ ] dude you know are you
doing anything for yourself you sound
like a butler you know that's the thing
these days it's tough it's weird it's
interesting though but it's also
interesting you know it's in
interesting because I mean women have
been look you know they have been looked
down upon and thought of as a lesser sex
for a long time and I think that there
needs to be some adjustment there and I
think this could be that correction
period you know and I hope that it is
but I don't hope that comedy gets ruined
because of this and my hopes are that we
can still joke you know and know what is
a joke and know what isn't that's one
thing that I hope but I appreciate that
call men that's a you know that's a lot
of thoughts and if some of you guys have
thoughts on that as well
hit me up I'd love to hear a little bit
more on that you know or do you feel
scared to be a man right now do you feel
like a lot of these issues that are
created out there and a lot of these you
know views of women and are created more
by women and then they are actually by
men you know it's like women are just
fighting these you know are playing both
sides of the net do you what do you
think you know or a man just been you
know you know because it's tough the
tough thing is if you're not a bad dude
if you're not a bad dude then this
doesn't apply to you but the problem is
some of these things are so blanket that
make it feel like it applies to everyone
and I know I'm all over the place
tonight man I don't even think I'm being
[ __ ] funny dude sorry but we're gonna
take one more caller and then we're
going to show today I really relate to
your comedy I like to think of myself
there's a bit of a Southern gentleman
not quite as listening whether that
accent is yours but I do
I do love listening news feed we got a
nice accent there too brother you got a
you know you got a you got a real
handsome tongue and you're in your in
your head um I have some problems with
like the thing grows and whatnot I used
marijuana as an agent to combat these
things and I was just kind of wondering
how you feel like in North Carolina so
legally use marijuana but in California
it's medicine how do you how do you feel
about that being something to help you
get off alcohol and other
don't usually well for me I don't use
marijuana I don't use anything you know
how does it suck yeah I want to crack my
brain open sometimes didn't eat the rib
meat off of my [ __ ] thought spheres
for sure you know I want to bust open my
damn [ __ ] brainstem you know and lick
that rib meat off them thoughts sickles
that are hanging up from the inside of
my cranium but I don't you know when I
have a you know so when I'm stressed or
whatever I does have to deal with it I
got to deal with my own thoughts I have
to deal with my own feelings you know
and for me that's what I need because if
the easiest thing for me to do is to
hide from my issues man my brain my
whatever is inside of me the problem
that is inside of me whatever it is it
is lazy and it is manipulative it will
manipulate me and if I have a problem
instead of dealing with it or thinking
through it or feeling through it my
brain I'm like oh yeah whatever have a
beer you know have a go do this go do
that go to bed take a nap jerk off look
at porn watch sport do something you
know don't don't solve whatever this
little thing is don't try and figure it
out
don't try to get help for yourself you
know so for me I don't use marijuana you
know no I'm not saying I never will I'm
not saying I'll always be this way but
for now you know I'm trying to live life
on life's terms man I'm trying to look
life straight in the eye when I have an
issue now you can't use it in North
Carolina legally people can in
California legally and I think it'll be
legal everywhere in a couple of years
you know so if you want it you're gonna
have it but I think that this is a time
when a lot of men when it's it is a
critical time I believe that when it
comes to you know instead of grabbing a
beer or grabbing a joint or a whip a
coat you know hitting one of them sheep
tails you know putting that
fluffernutter up your [ __ ] face hole
I think it's time to sit and think sit
and feel sit there why am i pen what's
going on what's got me
you know and figure it out get to the
other side of it you know so that that
way you know if you are having a drink
having a joint it's not reactionary and
it's something you just want to do
because you want to do it because that
was my problem I get reactionary so I'm
not a big proponent of that I don't
think is anything wrong with it if
you're high as [ __ ] right now and give a
[ __ ] I was over at Coco Diaz his podcast
the other day he's smoking weed and now
I don't care I love that man to the end
of the earth you know I don't care what
anybody else does but I'm just saying
for me that's what I do for now
but it's up to you man you know it's up
to you you know but I for me I'll find
too many excuses if I use uh if I use
other stuff right now find too many
excuses and right now I need to make
less excuses for myself and I need to at
least work towards having a little bit
more knowledge about what's going on
inside of my thoughts and feelings and
why I behave the way that I do so that I
can be on top of my behaviors and be a
step ahead of them at times because a
lot of times my behaviors are
reactionary and and and they're not my
first behaviors sometimes the first
choice up my whatever's wrong inside of
me wants to make isn't always the best
choice for me so I need to be aware and
be there I'm gonna take one more call
here from this guy he called him a
couple weeks ago and uh and I really
related to this call and then we're
gonna get out of here I just want to I
want to get his thoughts out here here
we go
hey Theo this is Chris I emailed you
earlier so that I'm dealing with this
stuff
so I'm gonna do my best to explain
what's going on so basically I'm I'm
kind of like you you know like your
similar upbringing didn't really have
like a dad around kind of had like a
mean mom thanks for calling Chris thanks
for sharing let's hear more so about
like my feelings or whatever how to talk
to the girls basically how to express my
feelings towards girls so ah man that
was the bane of my existence I didn't
realize it until recently that that was
what caused a lot of my issues was that
I couldn't I just couldn't reel I
couldn't I was afraid to talk to women
and that fear just resonated inside of
me let's hear more well I always kind of
had like a
so that I was too nice she was running
around my friends after that okay she
had a girlfriend she was too nice but
then so then she you were too nice and
she started running around with your
friends so let's hear more and that kind
of like maybe want to change myself so I
started to try to be a little bit more
edgy started drinking started smoking
started partying and that worked you
know I got a little bit more popular but
it didn't really help like with girls I
mean you know most of the time I would
end up like sleeping in the bushes or
something like that instead of you know
getting a girl yeah so you weren't
getting the girls so you started being a
certain way oh I need to drink more I
need to you know use drugs or do
something but to get the girls yep
that's most dudes so that's okay but
yeah I was exactly that way man I didn't
know who I was so I just knew that
whatever I was wasn't okay because women
didn't like me and the main reason that
I felt that way was because probably in
hindsight I felt like somewhere inside
of me I felt like my mother didn't
really like me probably I don't know
that's a big jump for some people
listening to this but that's you know as
I learn more about myself I realize that
I never you know that if I thought my
mother didn't like me you know and I
didn't feel that relationship with her
then I didn't really know how to relate
to women because that's your first
relationship for a young man and if my
relationship with her was kind of
damaged then you know my relationship
with all women was probably gonna be at
least you know off to a rocky start
because I didn't know even how to begin
one so once women weren't recognizing me
well or wasn't working then then yeah of
course you adjusted yourself you party
and now you smoke and you lay it in a
bush as you live in life let's hear more
oh to come home with me
and I just kept escalating and my mother
wasn't having it you know she she ended
up kicking me out the house after that I
ended up living in a shed for about six
months and that's when things really got
dark mmm and this kind of a you know a
tough call to hear I'm sure on a Monday
or whatever somebody got
are still you know if you guys listen to
the episode but you know this is life
man and this is what's going on and and
Chris called about ten days ago and this
call really meant a lot to me cuz it you
know I really I could relate to this a
lot Chris I could relate to a lot of the
things you're sharing because I felt a
lot of these same ways you know I didn't
all I wanted to do was feel the
affections of a woman somehow and not
even sexual I just wanted a woman to
think that I was okay but for some
reason when I was a kid something I
don't know what happened I don't know it
was before I was even able to know what
was going on I felt like how my mother
some our connection was not good and I
felt somewhere like I was not okay what
she didn't think I was okay or something
was not okay she did not accept me I
felt unaccepted by her so immediately
then every other woman I immediately
meet I already feel unaccepted by them
so then I changed myself I started being
different ways
acting outlandish acting this way being
loud being goofy whatever something
something to to alter that interaction
that I something to try any code I could
to crack to crack this comfortability
with women and make it feel more
comfortable and then yeah and my mom and
I was relationship of course was never
really getting strong
I got emancipated I went out was limb
with friends thankfully I didn't have to
live in a shed you know I was pretty
blessed that I had some good five
friends and different families that took
me in but let's hear more about your
story I'm just saying it's right
alongside let's go you know I had always
kind of been like a little bit depressed
because you know I didn't really have
like a person in my life like I was
alone basically so when I was in that
shed things got real dark you know I
would just stay up all night doing drugs
probably four times a day
maybe more than that jeepers dude oh if
I have to watch porn twice in it I feel
horrible I don't even do it I bet I'm
you know I'm a one-trick pony anyway
when it comes to sensuality
whether I'm doing self-pleasure or
actual sex if I'm doing sex let's hear
more and that went on for like six
months and this was a year ago
but yeah man so I got like some
dysfunction going on with me and the
crazy thing is is that like in order to
heal myself and to get better to do is
to get out there and meet somebody and
get into a relationship and start
getting out there but it's harder
because like I said I don't have that
drive I don't have the libido I don't
wake up in the morning and just have
that fire inside of me
cool man we'll look Chris I appreciate
you calling man the blink I really do
like a million percent I appreciate you
calling like a million percent dude and
you know you're not alone a lot of guys
have a lot of similar feelings and a lot
of similar issues man let's hear the end
of your call because I just feel bad
about cutting you off and plus I'm like
really you know I have low self
confidence just from you know I still
kind of see myself is like that homeless
dude jerking off in the shed yes you
have a low view your view of yourself
probably isn't always good
it sounds like man I'm sorry dude you
know I appreciate you telling you know
sharing this I really do you know and I
hope that by hearing this back and
listening to some of this you're able to
kind of get a little bit you know maybe
a it might you just a little more
perspective on yourself here I got to
plug this thing in really quick hold on
one second oh wait never mind the
plugins right here hold on sorry my
computer is on like 1% okay yeah look
man I can I can relate to this hundred
percent you know I really can self-worth
is low and a lot of that probably you
know and look I got to tell you I'm not
looking good I'm not any therapist I
have no idea the [ __ ] I'm talking about
you know I don't have any medical
background I have no I the only thing I
know is that I can when you tell me your
story right there Chris that I have
heard your story or parts of it inside
of myself you know and I've lived
through some of your story before
or maybe not exactly but I have not
heard had anyone call raka relate as
much to someone call and the thing that
helped me I'll be honest with you was
getting into a program dude it really
did
it helped me it really helped me I don't
know if you need a program you know if
you need a you know an AAA or an NA or a
CA I have no idea you know I don't know
if I'll be involved in that program
forever but for now I know that that
program has helped me get a better look
at myself to know who I really am you
know and it's hard man I've had to learn
slowly to be vulnerable in relationships
so that I can even build a connection
with a woman and this is slow stuff too
it is slow and it takes work but you can
feel better I promise
you know that's all I can tell you man
is that you can feel better and
relationships that haven't been good or
whatever will get better and that
somebody can love you and you can love
somebody else and you know and I can't
tell you what you know I I can't you
know you can't tell somebody to go get
in a program but you can just I can tell
you that for me it's changed my life
you know and sometimes that's hard for
me to even admit because sometimes I'm
so like self-centered or so you know
afraid to admit that anything other than
me has changed my life
because I'm so used to doing everything
for myself you know but when I'm really
honest yeah man that program has changed
my life I have a constant base of men
and other people that I can go to every
day to who to learn how to live in any
moment if I don't know something to do
there's somebody I can call there's 40
people I can call say hey what do i do
right now and like this is what you do
and there's these are people that I
trust and know and love and I know that
they love me and bam I do that because
those are the things you don't get when
you don't have like that relationship
with a mother relationship with the
father you don't get those you don't
have you don't know no one ever teaches
you anything
you know and it's hard to teach yourself
anything because you just you're so busy
just trying to survive
you know so sometimes it's hard to learn
but I Love You Man keep your head up you
know keep your head up dude you'll get
to your paradise city man we all going
to get there whether it's somebody that
wants marijuana out there and North
Carolina you know whether it's the guy
in the Pacific Northwest that just wants
to be able to share his feelings with a
woman butts afraid even if you can't
even talk to a woman anymore
about getting shut down but I don't
think it's gonna be forever man just we
just gotta just hold the line
hold the line it's okay we're gonna be
okay the man that's up there paying for
gas with change do you won't be paying
for gas with dollar soon brother but hey
dude it's funny you called in man you
made me reminded me when I used to pay
for gas and they roll in there with a
hot sock full of nickels [ __ ] drop
them on a counter walk out that's Darius
shoe then you brought the change but
they don't have to count that [ __ ] you
know but yeah it can be funny man laugh
at that [ __ ] next time you paying your
paradise city can be wherever they got a
fella just think about it did they got a
fell out and Brazil one of us eating
shrooms dude a 38 year old single man
dropping a voicemail like this is a
dating website but at the same time
letting us know that he's about to blast
off he's about to let his inner Buzz
Aldrin hit the stratosphere and that's
beautiful ty nice and who is still
hitting the email box
I only know the [ __ ] if you have
any idea what Tiny's hand who may look
like or not you're just guessing what is
a tiny sand who dropped me an email Theo
von at Mack ma c-calm hit me with that
sketch that artist rendition of some
tiny sand whoo and I'll see if I can't
incorporate some of them into into the
episode on Thursday maybe I'll put the
pictures in at the end of the video or
something on the YouTube you can find us
here subscribe please tell your friends
this episode honestly wasn't one of my
favorites in a lot of ways - my Energy's
a little bit low but but it meant a lot
to me that you guys called in and hit
the hotline
week nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three and I'm gonna keep
coming back you know I'm gonna keep
coming back and doing this because you
guys keep showing up for me and I
promise you it means a lot we stick
together in this [ __ ] you know we stick
together you know [ __ ] it the world's
gonna do what its gonna do this is just
so you know if you stay off the news a
lot of this shit's more chill dude I
laugh Trump does crazy stuff I think
from [ __ ] hilarious
Trump is hilarious dude you know
politician never did anything for me
anyway growing on I've never I think all
these politicians of [ __ ] I've been
buying out Bernie [ __ ] Bernie overall
everybody's all Pete all of these policy
they just rich man they rich they do a
rich [ __ ] anything about us they doing
rich [ __ ] we take care of ourselves we
take care of our kind we take care of
each other and I appreciate you being
here for me man on this past weekend
I'll see you guys really got a Thursday
edition coming out this week we got a
producer coming in a new producer
Wednesday night this boy so we're gonna
see how that works and thank you to
everybody that called in and offer
producer ship I'm still emailing some
people out and do some trial runs here
and there
see if well you know maybe we need
somebody on a Sunday maybe we need
somebody on a Wednesday I stuff to get
back to a few emails has just been kind
of a crazy week
you know I saw some tarantulas [ __ ]
though bruh and that some always wanted
to see hit the hotline with some of the
thoughts if you ever had a black friend
get nervous hit the hotline if you a
scared man out there you know [ __ ] I'm a
white man I'm feel like they trying to
kill me right now it's tough man but
hold on yourselves hold on to your loved
ones keep them close I'll talk to you
guys soon thank you
[Music]
celebrate
celebrate ms
[Music]